um hey what was I gonna ask you about
our vacation oh yeah you went to the
Philippines those pictures I even took -
did I message you where are you guys
I was sliding into your girl's DMZ I
don't care because we love you
I love you so [ __ ] much I would love
you so much but you'd be one of those
ones one of the ones where I walked into
you know me in my bedroom from the road
right and you're eating her butthole
right you're eating her butthole
remember can ya know yeah I would be
like walking onto the hallway
I got dude I'm gonna let that pass right
but just don't do it again
yeah no problem no projects all right
wet white well yeah yeah yeah wait have
you ever been has anybody ever walked in
on it you ever in having sex no we have
a ton of animals we have six yeah it's a
little weird yeah I mean um I'm not a
I'm not a I don't showcase publicly I'm
not an exhibitionist
no no no no I'm not saying I'm purpose
I'm just saying when you were a kid or
exploring your own dad oh my dad my dad
because my parents bathtub I think I've
said this before my parents bathtub in
their bedroom had such a strong you know
what's a faucet yeah such a strong water
pitcher I used to as a kid put my penis
Oh
like all my hands like this right yeah I
got my hands and leaves like this right
and then I would stick my penis give me
on the faucet I will turn it on and and
and the way the water hit my penis it
would make me a rack right yeah and so
and I would I would jump a little bit
like not close did you have to get real
close I'll bet huh what the faucet yeah
you know that's it felt good because of
the distance between the faucet or my
people got just that it was a perfect
you know I think it was
too closely with the pressure would been
hurtful yeah right
yeah cuz did the water just go between
your penis and the wall it's a small
dick job I know I was just trying to
defend myself II know that was you
really and then this is what I so one
day I was doing it and this is what I
hear right and I'm then I stopped
jerking yeah yeah I turned my head like
this yeah and my dad's going laughing
and laughing at me and he just walked
out of the bathtub and he never talked
about it
it's not one of those saying your dad so
with us yeah he's still with that mom -
yeah okay and I've never brought it up
again well yeah I don't yeah yeah
because he's only laughed like that
twice that time can I just say you were
holding up three fingers right then when
you said twice
you said he's only done that he's only
left like that twice yeah I have carpal
tunnel okay so no I'm sorry twice that's
still three it doesn't [ __ ] matter
okay okay
yeah and the second time you did that is
when I was in rehab and I told him in
front of the whole rehab that I was
molested by a guy with Down syndrome and
he laughed like that to the whole family
or a whole family
so this is a - and so people ask me so
glum and moody that's why that's the
origin that's it
[Music]